/ dancing you're a chair of the Nobel
Prize Committee in physics and this
year's prize is awarded for an invention
that was conferred the greatest benefit
to mankind it's something that Alfred
Nobel would be happy about as you
mentioned in the press conference can
you explain it a bit more I I really
think that Alfred Nobel would be very
happy about this price at three and
invention and it's really something that
will benefit most people artificial
lighting is everywhere around us and
this is a way to make artificial
lighting much more efficient than other
older light sources it also gets rid of
some of the problems that we have with
with for instance fluorescent light
sources which use mercury and and these
ones don't have that and so we can get
rid of the mercury but there are also
other uses which are maybe not so big
today but in the future maybe we will
see portable devices that can disinfect
water or two to sterilize water because
UV light can can can kill bacteria and
almost everyone has seen an LED light as
we have it in our yeah but most people
have seen this kind of smartphone where
you have a flashlight which uses this
LED technology in fact also the screen
of the of the smartphone is using LED
technology and many TV sets etc are
using our computer screens are using
this technology
you have a bright light from the
telephone as the one you showed now the
hard thing here is that the price is
awarded for invention of a blue light
wedding day out there so how does it go
together well it's it's so that to get
white light you really need to combine
at least three different colors so
typically you do mix red and green and
blue and this is well known this is
actually known since Isaac Newton in
1671 but it was so the red and the green
LEDs have been around for a long time
but the blue one has really been missing
and so now these laureates have have
made the inventions that made it
possible to make efficient blue LEDs and
so now we have that and we can mix it
with the red and the green and that
provides white light sources so what did
they do that the others failed to make
yeah so this is very interesting because
there's also what's fascinating is that
that a lot of big companies really try
to do this and they failed but these
guys persisted and they tried and try it
again and eventually they actually
succeeded and you can say there's two
two major things they did one was just
to grow a sufficiently good material
this is this is called gallium nitride
and that was very hard to grow and to
get a good material and they managed to
do that and the second part was to dope
it in the right way in semiconductors
like this you you dope both electrons
and holes and it was the whole doping
which was very difficult but they
succeeded in doing that too so and and
it was really an effort that we're all
the three-peat
people were contributed to this okazaki
and imani worked together in one lab and
nakamura worked in another life and they
made it in parallel yes they very much
made it in parallel and they made
different versions of it and they sort
of improved each other's results this
seems like a giant step in making light
actually because until now it was mainly
fire that was producing hi so what's
interesting is that this kind of this
way of making light is actually getting
quite close to the theoretically
possible way so that every time you put
in one electron you get one particle of
light a photon out and and that's the
maximum you can get and and these these
LED sources are actually going towards
that goal so it will be hard to find
something that will be better so we will
be left with this now for ever I think
so they will of course improved over the
years and and become a little bit better
but it will you will not get anything
that will be you know ten times better
there's not room for that so we are all
ready now as good as they can be oh not
quite but there are over fifty percent
efficiency yeah and you can only go two
hundred and the Lord's Day work in Japan
in two different yes so all all of the
three are born in Japan and they worked
in Japan when they did this work but
Nakamura has namo moved to California
and it's in Santa Barbara
how did they react when the telephone
call came from Stockholm today well they
were that they were of course quite
pleased and nakamura we woke up in the
middle of the night this so it was the
two o'clock in the morning and so but
because he's in these things he's in
California right now and akasaki he was
in that for him it was evening so he was
of course away but amano he's on an
airplane from from Japan to France right
now so we didn't reach him so hopefully
there will be people meeting him at the
airport and giving him the good news
thank you for dancing for being here